a day after giving her State of the
Union addressed in Brussels where she
said Vladimir Putin was waging an energy
war on Europe the president of the
European commission made an unannounced
trip to Kiev Ursula vanderlein came with
a clear message you have your European
Friends by your side as long as it takes
and that we are friends forever
bundelion and Ukrainian president
voldemir zielinski appear to have
respect for one another zelenski
unveiled a plaque outside Parliament
honoring the EU leader after they held
closed-door meetings
Wonderland committed to 5 billion in
loans to Ukraine and 250 million for
schools and temporary housing for people
displaced by the war but she stopped
short of committing to any new Russian
sanctions something keep has been asking
for
underlying announced that she will be
hosting a Ukraine reconstruction
Congress at the end of October in Berlin
where she will be bringing together
people to discuss how much money Ukraine
will need to rebuild and where to get
that money from and that amount could
keep going up because Ukraine continues
to be destroyed as this country's War
continues
late Wednesday night Russian cruise
missiles hit a dam in southern Ukraine
forcing water to overflow a local River
and partially flooding
a city of six hundred thousand that is
zelenski's Hometown
we understand that at the destroyed Dam
there were no Ukrainian military units
it doesn't surprise me that Russia's
hitting civilian infrastructure because
they've done it before
it was the second strike on civilian
infrastructure in recent Days by the
Russians after they also bombed a
thermal power plant in the Northeast
temporarily cutting power to Ukraine's
second largest city
while Wonderland wanted to talk about
rebuilding the ukrainians continue to
call for what they consider more
immediate needs weapons that they say
are the only way to end the war Gabriel
ozando Al Jazeera Kiev